you know and welcome to this video
playing boss and Hicks get something
from physic right physics does he play
you know he does okay Carol two nights
they all play that it's really in
fashion understandably it's an
interesting line from blacks perspective
you know I always have to think about it
for a moment yeah it's not like I mean I
know my repertoire and the repertoire
that I compiled but it is sometimes
still it takes a moment to reflect
what's going on in and then I can learn
I can play the line yeah this is I'm
probably going for Bishop to b5
something that I can prevent with night
eggs here why not let's try it
interesting interesting position 96m
looks very very logical the question is
do I want to take or I can try Knight f3
just go back maybe just don't help him
with trades
Queeny to be should be three next moves
black IAM always has to find a good
solution for the king the King only
eight yeah
currently it's actually reasonably safe
there but you will basically never never
cancel short that's not going to happen
so you have to Castle queenside not easy
to do
that such a huge question is f/8 better
than a seven
hmm why am I not getting something no
like there's a there's a sacrifice oh
but this isn't the case so what's going
on here what is going on here
to just make this a little bit sounder
and then see what black is doing c4 can
also be an idea absolutely it's not so
easy here to to handle this with the
black pieces I guess
yes to call we're a seven looks correct
so Bishop III Bishop c5 I am not quite
certain I would probably do this this
first so it's never it's not canceling
anymore that's good good thing I guess
to deform
maybe he can cancel short it's not like
I'm meeting him immediately
maybe it is possible to do that okay so
I've gained huge space on the queenside
yeah I'm out for Queen a3 yeah let's go
to be to Queen a three on the right down
so yeah maybe eight yeah so check King
hmm it says some way to I mean blacks
blacks position looks pretty awful the
only thing I see is a Queen c7 Quebec
I've got King D to em I just have kingly
to and g4 g5 is a simple threat no yeah
that's it he has no moves
it's got no moves
you know but there was no way out there
anyway that turned out to be really
really nice complete complicated
complicated game okay so here a black
played Bishop to d7 um if he wants to be
let's say more certain of the trade
maybe he should start with actually
taking on before I will take with the
night though anyway hmm yeah okay Bishop
d7 Bishop d3 so we have the capture he
could go Bishop b5 now maybe simply not
allowing not allowing me to take engine
wants to take a play for okay I would
even assume that I'm that I'm so bit
better here just just because of space
but probably not the best possible way
to play he'd take a force what the
engine is is giving so Queen a six and
then Knight G I am okay so Queen a six
isn't all that great because I can't
immediately attack a problem is that it
moves like that just doesn't work yet we
need three is killing there's just no
way for the Queen to cover f7
interesting so okay he took I took with
the night I prevent who trade and he I
decided to keep it on the board you know
it's it's probably better I can cannot
imagine that I'm better here
as always honey that the engine wants to
take but this is a decision that a human
player is really having a hard time with
and I don't think it's good there are
cases in neuroscience where you can
maybe take but this is not one of them
and particularly because I have no night
sometimes when you have a night you can
in those lines you can sometimes support
this somehow and get some pressure but
that doesn't work in okay I went back to
have three Bishop c5 Queenie to a five
that might make a lot of sense prevent
before after I got before in I felt I'm
in really good shape in a three maybe no
that's not the most forceful move but it
it makes sense I prepare see form and
I'm just waiting for a bit I don't want
to castle if IIF you know after b5 must
be a really nice position a for Knight
c8 was better trying to play queen d8
not to b6 okay yeah yeah that that's
problem that's really awkward yeah
because he don't really like to take on
the form and what are you playing and
quinces Queen c7 okay g4 was even better
than Queen to be too
a knight c6 Wow Wow
that would have been absolutely shocking
him to face 96 Wow
yeah I am once you see you kind of use
him yeah and then the night coming to
before will at least keep like yeah safe
from an immediate disaster something
like this it's so beneful right but it's
a huge difference if this is all before
and compared to like here that's
something you can really overlook
I mean both sides just with black it's
it's kind of it's a bit of a hidden
resource that's it this is an
interesting question how can you find a
move like knight c6 um I think in blitz
it's difficult anyway he had no time he
had 10 seconds 15 seconds whatever
not much but even in even in a longer
time control game it it maybe this is
this rule trying to improve the worst
place pieces maybe this is helpful like
9 on a7 is really bad and if you more
actively think about how can you improve
it you will probably end up with moving
the rukon see a plane I'd see it but if
you have the knight in the back of your
mind that maybe the Knights is six uh
markers to you it can also help to think
about unprotected pieces like the Queen
moving to be two moves on an unprotected
piece an unprotected square I mean so it
is an unprotected piece now and this
combination maybe can bring you to the
point that you think about knight c6 it
would have been a huge difference really
after after this I'm just winning g4 g5
you cannot cannot really defend it but
here I would play King the two words
from the best and then g5 is such a
devastating threats it's just nothing to
do okay guys thanks for watching